last year you remember this prince harry
and his wife meghan markle
who have officially retired from the
royal family signed a
podcast deal with spotify worth tens of
millions of dollars it was a really big
story
well last month we revealed that the
royal family retaliated with its
own podcast starring queen elizabeth and
prince charles
and we're very excited apparently they
just released
another episode welcome to fiddlesticks
i'm your host queen elizabeth and i'm
prince charles on today's show we're
going to answer listener emails
oh how exciting tabitha from
johannesburg
wants to know how long have you been
queen
lovely question tabitha 68 years
astonishing her majesty that record
won't be broken for a long time
not by you that's for sure your majesty
these kind of jokes always put me in an
awkward position
that's what i tell them speaking of
positions do you need to fill any
at your company no your majesty zip
recruiter
is the world's number one job search app
if you are hiring or
looking for a job just use the promo
code
what's the job for 20 off
i can't imagine getting a job from an
app and not your mother's
funeral
sorry ma'am it was it was a joke
you